[Music]
[Applause]
Cam Newton he's got a podcast it's uh
called fourth in one on Cam's YouTube
channel each and every Wednesday
throughout the season yours truly
will'll be on it uh tomorrow so I'm
going to see how cam does asking the
questions Cam Newton joining us on the
program uh how what kind of hat you got
on there what what what are we sporting
there mashika hat you got to get you one
uh Mr Dan Patrick sir uh based in La
also have a space in BOS Montana I send
you some uh drip some Swag yeah all
right I'm good uh how's the uh how's the
broadcasting career going man you tell
me one thing about um media I think you
don't necessarily have a coach to tell
you if what you're doing right or wrong
your coach is your audience and you just
got to lean in and give the people what
they want okay but you have the Riz as
the kids like to say you have the
Charisma yeah yeah you always had that
but yes sir you know that what I would
tell you is be curious even if you know
the answer to something your audience
may not know the answer but always be
curious when you're talking to when
you're interviewing somebody and listen
to what they have to say because your
next question could be something that
they just said and those are usually
tips I give to broadcasting students but
just be curious what did you major in at
Auburn uh
Sports Hey listen you got a master's
degree in that a master's degree in that
for sure uh and that was a layup and
people TL who's watching it I majored in
uh money marketing uh but that's neither
here nor that that flew over a lot of
people's heads but
officially um I majored in
sociology and I realized at a young age
I hated school but I love people and it
wasn't the the course that I was taken
it was the person who was teaching the
course that I was taking that that
really that really caught me so when I
lean into sociology that really is the
study of people and I was able to you
know really get consumed by the the
whole mental aspect of what people and
people do what they do in in some way
shape form but I wonder about today's
athlete going to college that should we
teach them what everybody else is you
know all these subjects that you know
maybe you're not going to be putting
them into play if you want to be a
professional athlete and I maintain I
brought this up with Kentucky players if
you were going for one year how about we
teach you about real estate uh balancing
a checkbook Investments uh picking an
agent like stuff that if if you're going
there for basketball you're not going
there for an education so let's not fool
anybody let's give you some things that
you can take it's a one-year class and
and then maybe you'll get these kids
that maybe they want to come back for
another year or at least they're
prepared a little bit more than the
history of Mesopotamia that's not going
to help you when you're playing for
Carolina correct I mean I've always been
intrigued about uh unraveling The Core
Essence of educ
and we are forced in some ways to to do
things that we don't necessarily really
want to do it should be opinionated by
what I want to do um just found this out
you know there's certain curriculums
like aaries that just cater to certain
things that the child wants to do at a
at an ear early age so when we see Tiger
Woods when we see these exceptional
athletes at the early age like Venus
Williams and Serena they have dedicated
their lives at at that age to do that I
think athletes can can cope with that
but also from the age of Education side
we should be able to choose and have
that curriculum taught to us without
having all the fluff in it as well too
so what would what would you teach if
you could go back and talk to the 22y
old Cam Newton either on the field or
off the
field controlling your brand image
likeness and the purpose of it I think
there is a very intriguing time in media
right now that I'll ask you this
question what did you study in
college uh
broadcasting
right but for
me you didn't study
football right yeah well like you're a
double major like you you had football
and you had there you know whatever you
were you know discussing as education
right but but to my point is this
there's a time in media where as a
broadcaster you're able to talk about
football but now the football players
have an opportunity to broadcast yeah
you know and and you see it in in real
time with Pat McAfee I don't think or I
don't necessarily know uh Pat's
um educational kind of uh growth uh play
but I say all that to say for me I've
went through it through having real
personal experiences and had I if I go
back to that 20 year old self that 22
year old self I would take on just the
importance of controlling that because
you're talking to a person obviously
I've been in the media a time or two and
been burnt so it's easy for me to have
these conversations because I never want
the guest or the talent to feel like I
exploited them for clickbait yeah so I
know how to be curious I know how to
shut my ass up too and let talk but more
importantly you know this is a very
intriguing time in media where people
who get it they're winning and you don't
necessarily have to go into journalism
or broadcasting to be able to be
intriguing enough for the audience to to
uh tune in to your show he's Cam Newton
uh his podcast fourth in one drops on
Cam Newton's YouTube channel ches and
Tuesday and it airs on uh Wednesday
when's the last time a team called you
about
playing
uh two years oh two
years yeah now did you reach out to any
team have you reached out or your agent
like the Browns when you know you had
Watson going down or the Jets did you
reach out your agent no no interest a
lot of interest but no
you want them to call you not the other
way
around I know it doesn't matter how many
times you call if they don't want you
they're
not so at the end of the day I I I've
I've known the the NFL to do and be very
intentional in what they do it's no
manipulation it's no sway it doesn't
matter if I call them if they don't want
me it's it's still going to be a
okay but why are you not playing you're
34 um I don't
know you haven't been told
that
injuries
what uh Mr Daniel
yeah your guess is as best as mine um
but honestly for me I'm I'm really I'm
really locked in and focused on the
things that I can control right now but
are you too big of a personality for
some teams does that scare people do you
think I think it I've said it before yes
yeah what do you say to a Dak Prescott
what do you say to a Derek Carr what do
you say to a healthy Deshawn Watson what
do you say
to you know at that particular point in
time um Zack
Wilson Cam Newton's coming in
town but B all means you know we want
you to be the best version of yourself
well the backup quarterback can't be a
bigger more popular than the starting
quarterback like Tim TBO it's hard to
bring in TBO I always thought because
he's going to get so much attention and
he's not going to be
playing yeah but you're a better
quarterback in the NFL that's
discretionary um to the to the viewer
because no that's real in the NFL you
know you're are you a Hall of Famer in
your eyes
oh Dam you do you taking me to school
right now ain't
you the legend I want you to learn I
want you to I want you to learn oh my
God you you are taking me to uh uh
broadcasting for dummies right
now are you a Hall of
Famer hell yeah okay all right uh now it
for me my impact to the game oh let me
ask you this
what's more important impact or
championships you Dan Patrick would you
rather have a Robert or's
career right or an alen Iverson
career I'd rather be
AI why because
that's that's
longevity uh cultural he changed the
game he changed the game in a lot of
ways how you look what you wear how you
play um he he was he never cheated me
Robert Ory had you know 10 15 you know
unbelievable moments and won seven
titles but Allen Iverson was a badass
from start to finish yes sir so I will
ask you this question what would you
take you want Robert Ory winning
championships or you want alen Iverson
who played in one NBA final so you're
sitting up here telling me and lot of
way shape form I am Alan Iverson I only
played in one Super Bowl yeah you
culturally uh start to finish um
polarizing um but you know what I knew
that when you were in the game so even
even to that point and and what do we
teach student athletes now be a team
player yes you want to be a team player
but also you must understand Sports has
so many different determining factors in
it for you to be a team player let's
take uh uh certain field goals going
either way certain rules being in place
does Tom Brady still have as many
championships as he has or Super Bowls
that that he has right adamary helped
you yes exactly that's my point so
there's so many different things that
you could do but yet still come up short
so if you're asking me the original
question is is Cam Newton and Hall of
Famer my impact to this game is without
a doubt seen right so that's that point
even to the to the situation we saw last
night uh Patrick Mahomes can do
everything in his right to try to make
the team win but you still can't make
you catch it you can't make them catch
you can't make people blocking you can't
make a defensive uh unit stop the
opposing team either all right I got to
take a break here I'm going to be on
your podcast coming up in about a half
hour from now so you want to load up and
come after me with fire you can come
after me with fire just remember I've
always got an extinguisher I always have
a fire extinguisher just letting you
know all right now here's the question I
want to leave you with this did you ever
think about having an outfit if you lost
a game when you'd go to those press
conferences and you would have whatever
you had on and you just lost did you
ever think about bringing a losing
outfit or what would have been in a loss
not a losing outfit but in a loss you
would have warned that to the press
press conference instead of what you
arrived with absolutely not because it
would have distracted me and and gave me
a a cop out right so I I committed I
jumped as they would say it and when I
when I went into each and every game I
had a different mentality that sparked
either my um you know me being intrigued
to where what sparked me that particular
week and and I just Tred to show it
through fashion it was awesome I loved
it but we gotta get to a hat that's what
we got to do yeah what are the Dre what
what are the dreads look like under
there I mean how much hair you got It's
A Wig but you know in our culture
Dan when we take our dreads that means
we're extremely excited so I'm shaking
my dreads right now all right you're
kind of like Jay-Z's dreads or Jay-Z is
kind of like my oh okay all right here
we go all right uh I'll talk to you I'll
talk to you in a little bit absolutely
looking forward to it thank you that's
Cam Newton he's got a podcast fourth in
one and it's on Cam's YouTube channel
each and every Wednesday throughout the
season